all right springs just started it's
early april
you know we might be in quarantine but
at least that means i've got plenty of
time to watch all the spring anime that
i want to watch
oh are you watching the new summer anime
summer
what are you talking about spring just
started
what the [ __ ] hey guys [ __ ] here
back at it again with another seasonal
rundown it's summer 2020 and before i
figure out where the hell april may and
june [ __ ] up to
this year we got some more anime to
watch now i know this year has been a
complete dumpster fire so far but what
more can we ask for than to dive
straight into some seasonal anime to
help us forget all the troubles
happening in the real world
so let's see what we got
[Music]
me
[Music]
we're all doomed aren't we
yes
i do wonder to myself at what point does
the series become so over the top that
even though it plays it completely
straight it just becomes satire is it
when your overpowered protagonist is
casually eating a castle into [ __ ]
narnia or is it when your overpowered
protagonist wants to flex in his
opponent
so hard that he beats him to death with
a literal
heartbeat
and then he just golden experience
requiems him so he can do it again
this is the biggest power fantasy trash
i've seen in a while
i love it the show doesn't even try to
pretend to be something it's not and
it's great
half the time i don't know whether i
should be impressed or laughing at how
ridiculously overpowered the protagonist
is
and he's only like a month old too what
what the [ __ ]
is there anything he can't do anna's
vaulty goat is officially
the giga chad of 2020. this man just
does it all when annos was born he drove
his mum home when he makes a tasteless
joke twitter makes an apology video
he can [ __ ] your girl without losing his
virginity because
he never loses this man is so op
he managed to get a tundra to be true to
her feelings in a single
episode he's too dangerous to be left
alive now normally i kind of just gloss
over all the sequels to make room for
more of the new shows but um
well here are all the new anime from
winter 2020.
here are all the new anime from spring
2020 and here are all the new anime for
summer
2020 yeah
oh man it's been so many years i've made
me so much i forgot it was a legitimate
plot point three zero is finally back
and it's got
no chill jesus what the [ __ ] is going on
it's now been four years since the
original series aired and all it needed
was four minutes to remind me holy hell
i missed this goddamn show just in the
first two episodes is pretty much
dealing with the major problem i had
with the original the world and
characters of re-zero always felt super
interesting but all it was missing was
that big overarching plot to tie it all
together
and that seems like exactly what's being
set up this is looking like it could way
exceed the first season and if you have
any interest in re zero at all your hype
level should be
off the charts unless of course you're a
ram fan
who it seems in the last ditch effort
for the fight for best girl has resorted
to the domestic girlfriend coma strat
origairu season 3 is also here i'm hype
or at least i would be if i had finished
season 2.
oh yeah i was gonna go through my plan
to watch this during quarantine wasn't i
wonder why that didn't happen
where the [ __ ] did all my time go the
thing i like about anime original shows
is that everyone comes in with zero
expectations
everyone is on equal footing we all have
zero idea what kind of ride we're about
to get on and we all get to be
equally surprised decadence is a new
anime original coming from the director
of mob psycho season one and two and on
the outside it seems to be something
like mad max in the franxx with a little
bit of attack on titan sprinkled in it's
a post-apocalyptic setting with monsters
which we've seen before so as i was just
waiting for that one hook to get me
invested to hop on this ride
a [ __ ] city transforms into a giant
fist and then just one punches this
kaiju out of existence and i was like
all right respect you got my [ __ ]
attention but then to top things off it
throws this darling in the franxx let's
go to space scale twist right on episode
two that completely flips the entire
setting on its head
apparently the entire world is some kind
of avatar type theme park for these
alien looking things and all humans are
oblivious to that fact this is
definitely one of the most unique setups
i've seen but with so many things going
on this has the potential to be one of
the most interesting ideas that's been
pulled off all year
or an absolute [ __ ] either way
i'm excited for the ride
in the culture corner we have peter
grill the world's strongest fighter who
only wants to do one thing
saving his chastity for the one true
love of his life and the only thing
standing in his way is the flurry of
sexy anime woman
after his seed
mission failed successfully
this year we've somehow gone from hentai
sitcom to ntr
comedy and you know it's somewhat
refreshing now the itchy anime aren't
afraid to explore the topic of their
protagonists having full-blown
intercourse
even if that does blur the line even
further but you know what
after interspecies reviewers i think i
finally found the line between i can't
believe it's not hentai an actual hentai
instead of ugly bastards we just keep
seeing lucky bastards your accent is
very unique
it's like a weird jumble of
different dialects why did you even
learn that
now this one looks good so netflix here
in japan have released the first 14
episodes of the great pretender which
basically follows a group of con artists
traveling around the world
scamming people the first story arc
revolves around them trying to swindle a
drug lord into spending millions of
dollars to buy a new drug that doesn't
actually exist
this is looking like a cross between a
heist movie and steven spielberg's catch
me if you can it's incredibly refreshing
not only to see a concept you don't
normally see in anime but such a global
setting handled an aesthetic reminiscent
of 80s hollywood
singapore london shanghai tokyo we start
off in la but the show will be staged
around the world and i am absolutely
hyped
this is one show i'll actually probably
wait to be dubbed since there's even a
segment that explains that the
characters are actually speaking english
also the ed is actually the original
great pretender sung
by freddie mercury where else can you
say you've seen an anime that has a song
sung by freddie freaking mercury
continuing the netflix train they also
just dropped the entirety of japan
sinks from masaki uasa following the
tragic story of a family trying to
survive the biggest natural disaster the
world has ever seen
and you've got exactly what you can
expect from a series like this
desolate scenes of a country ravaged by
disaster
the horrors of losing your loved ones
and trying to fight to survive
a wheelchair-bound grandpa that's
[ __ ] 360 no stroking people with a
bloody bow and arrow we've got kill bill
standoffs there's a bloody weed farm in
the middle of japan
it's got sex it's got action it's got
drugs so yeah
everything you can expect from a series
like this
[Music]
overall best comedy anime of 2020 so far
only in anime would you be able to make
a show about a group of high school
teenagers to gain superpowers from
erotic energy fighting invading aliens
who want to drain all the thought energy
in the world
yes that is the plot of the show i am
not making this up we literally have
power rangers fueled by the strength of
horny on main
or as i like to call it hentai sentai
this is one of those shows that has an
uncensored version to accompany it if
you know what i'm saying but
i mean how bad can it be
[Music]
i apologize for that even for me this is
a little bit too much degeneracy
disgusting
that's him ladies that's the guy
subscribe to build all fiends only fans
we have what seems to be umaru chan 2.0
mega milk edition looks like a nice
little wholesome show i don't know what
it is about smug anime girls bullying
male characters that seem to be getting
anime adaptions nowadays
maybe it's just something about this
facial expression man because if we just
take a screenshot and analyze it
you can almost hear them laughing at all
the komi fans on suicide watch overall
i'm very much looking forward to this
anime
not because i'm gonna watch it i just
have a feeling this will go in the
categories of shows i never finish but
we'll read every dojinshi because for
some reason they're all [ __ ] amazing
you know everyone's going to be talking
about how sao returns in the most
sao way possible but you know aside from
that instance let me just fill you in
where the series is right now the
americans have flooded the server with
drones of american gamers of this top
secret vr game that's being used to
develop an ar that could possibly run
the american military
and the only thing that can stop them
from doing so is kirito and the girls
uniting the japanese gamers to flood the
servers on their end and preventing the
americans from getting their hands on
this ai that could change the world
that's right the plot of sao is now
literally unironically gamers rise up
and it's great how can you not love this
how is this not the peak
sao we all wanted it to be kirito being
afk is a vegetable in a wheelchair still
getting more girls than any of us ever
will it's gotten so bad that even the
harem has become self-aware
cinon being a pure chad exuding big dick
energy exerting dominance right in front
of kirito's gamer girl wife and they
even gave klein a badass moment
[ __ ] incline shut up kirito
come back to me when you're a main
character continue shooting on sao if
you need continue cheating on kirito
i don't mind i'm having a great [ __ ]
time over here what the hell
this game is a rare sack rent a
girlfriend more
like wait a minute i got this
i got this just give me a second
simping am i right
here's the newest rom-com to arrive in
the anime scene where the premise is
literally in the title do you just
straight up pays to go for some pure
unadulterated unprotected hand-holding
disgusting which is basically the
premium only fans exclusive tier where
she pretends to be your girlfriend for a
few hours and then
anime stuff happens while this may look
like your box standard harem anime
there's something about it that just
works maybe it's the premise itself
maybe it's the fact that it's set in
college for once and the characters
actually act like horny teens who think
about sex or maybe it's the fact that
chizuru is so clearly best girl that i
don't even need to see any of the other
prospects to pledge my allegiance and
enlist to fly off into battle for her
but i was immediately addicted from
episode 1 and it's one of those shows
that i'm probably just gonna immediately
binge the manga finally topping things
off we have god of high school following
from tower of god as the second webtoons
anime adaptation this time about a
martial arts tournament that's held in
seoul where the winner gets granted
any wish they desire and um
wait that's it you're telling me this
anime is just one
massive martial arts tournament and what
it's just gonna be a series of well
animated and hyped fights
that's it that's the show
is it time is this the show that's
actually gonna do it
i said i wasn't gonna shout it anymore
it's a dead meme now
but maybe maybe there is only one way
i can possibly describe this show
yeah i mean it was right